certains patientent depuis l'aube dans
la tente d'un test face à l'explosion du
nombre de contaminations
la ville de mexico a déployé plus de 200
tentes de dépistage dans les quartiers
les plus touchés par l'épidémie
des test rapide et gratuit mais face à
un afflux massif de la population
les files s'allongent et les autorités
peinent à atteindre l'objectif de 20
mille tests quotidiens
pourquoi cela prend si longtemps il y a
beaucoup de demandes et malheureusement
ça réagit lentement
c'est notre troisième tentative de
passer le test
selon une récente estimation de
l'université d'oxford
le mexique est l'un des pays qui
effectuent le moins de tests au monde
priorité aux personnes âgées et à celles
et ceux qui présentent les symptômes les
plus sévères
mais à mesure que le nombre de cas
augmente les entreprises demandent de
plus en plus à leurs employés de se
faire dépister
nous délivrons un certificat officiel
scellé par mexico
beaucoup viennent ici pour cette raison
parce qu'on leur a demandé au travail de
passer le test
il y a aussi beaucoup de gens qui
présentent des symptômes et nous les
testons face aux pics d'hospitalisation
dans la capitale le gouvernement mise
sur une campagne de dépistage massive
pour tenter d'endiguer l'épidémie le
mexique lui vient tout juste
d'enregistrer son record quotidien de
contamination avec plus de 12000 cas
quant au nombre de décès enregistrés
dans le pays
il s'établit à plus de 105 milles